i've got i wanna i wanna talk about
something else because i think this
matters
biden slashes stimulus checks for
americans making more than eighty
thousand dollars
president bows to pressure from moderate
democrats and will hand out fewer direct
payments than under trump
fewer than under trump which moderate
democrats are like this
but just can i just kind of talk about
how brutal it must be to have voted for
joe biden
thanking the democrats where to get you
this check and now you're being told by
the news
actually trump was trying to get you
more that is gotta be like
a kick in the walls you know those
tweets where people are like you know
you you sure
are like you know spending a lot of
money when you owe me money right
yeah it's like these switches like you
sure are you know vaporizing syrians
when you owe me a lot of money
biden's uh sure got a lot of money for
somebody who owes me two thousand
dollars
exactly you sure got a lot of money for
missiles yeah it's like
how insane is it we're the only country
in the world where they force
everybody out of their jobs and stay
home and then don't give them any money
to make it
look good i pulled this meme up
it's fine i didn't make it i just saw
people sharing it and i reposted it i
don't know who made it
it's yours now it is the hand pushing
one of the two buttons
vaporizing sirians is red and two
there's another chex is blue and then
it's dr robotnik jim carrey going
and pressing the red button joe biden
all the democrats said vote for the
democrats two thousand dollar check
donald trump said two thousand dollar
check mitch mcconnell was like well
slow around there trump so the
republicans
said no the democrats said yes and
everyone said i'll vote for the
democrats
and then the democrats it's it's it's
wonderful it's like
they gave they all voted to give the one
ring to joe biden
and they followed him into the fires you
know of mount doom
and then they're like cast the two
thousand dollar checks into the mailbox
and then biden turns around and goes no
and then walks out with the money and
then hands him to a military-industrial
complex guy and then press a button and
fires missiles
and goes kills kids or whatever i think
what you said earlier about us being
co-op that our government being
basically occupied
is is is extremely astute like after
woodrow wilson signed the federal
reserve act and basically sold us out to
this power and then after
world war ii when they made the liberal
economic order
and established these military bases all
over the world uh
it's like a parasite in the brain of our
country it's crazy slow down there ron
paul i love ron paul ron this is for you
that's right
we still so for christmas luke put ron
paul on top of the tree
because he's both a star and an angel
and now now the picture is just like on
the window ron paul's amazing guy
and i always tell people that the reason
have you seen that video that's going
viral from 1988
yes of course where him on more on more
not more on maury
no no no no i don't know it was just one
of those shock jock
hoes right from that
and then he's like yeah and by the way
you fatty you should lose some weight
too
no no he was like the government can't
make you a good person
why don't they why don't they put you on
a diet you're a little overweight and
the guy's like oh how dare you
it's a good point like i'm a doctor it's
he isn't he's a doctor he's probably
right yeah
the government can't make you be a good
person so i'm thinking about
this parasite in the brain of our
country and how do you remove a parasite
without it killing the host because this
is blue goo
that's blue right you can't yank it out
because it will kill the host
you can't you can try and kill it but if
it knows you're trying to kill it it
will kill the host
likely so you need to subvert it you
need to massage the affected area
until it starts wiggling its way out and
then you get the forceps and you slowly
pull very
slowly otherwise it could rip and then
retreat back in so yeah
so you make the host less enticing to
the parasite so we have to poison pill
ourselves
or well no there's no real analogy for
that
i think you know you create a system
that's not conducive to the parasite
i don't think that's a good analogy
because it's one planet it would be like
if there was one host and literally no
other host i think the us
has been is the host the us government i
think the whole planet
is basically got a bunch of powerful
interests that collude with each other
for a variety of reasons you're right
the british government too
yeah it's not like it's funny how people
are like you're a conspiracy theorist
it's not a conspiracy thing there's
international businesses that do deals
with each other
right and so you've got trump being like
he comes out into the
by the white house or the helicopter or
whatever and the the press asks him like
what's going on he goes we're going to
be selling a ton of weapons to saudi
arabia it's great we're going to make
tons of money it's great for the economy
and it's like it's right there in your
face
he's saying it i love that by the way it
was one of the greatest moments of
trump's presidency
watching all the all the anti-war left
just go like
he just said it he said all the
questions
my favorite tweet ever was this
journalist who's like i have been
working on this story for a year
all year and he just says it he just
sets it up he just tweeted it out he
just tweeted it out
that was huge that was huge that was
right around the same time as let's do
a little game theory oh man yeah so
uh i i do think think about this
when we got off the gold standard it's
really amazing
once once the the banking institutions i
i think it's silly to say the banks are
in charge or the fed
there's clearly just people in power and
wealthy interests who just use these
machines in these systems
to maintain control yeah the bank for
international settlements
it's it's it's it's like the mother
brand you know the bis
the liberal economic order you called it
yeah they've established it in like 1946
i think right after world war ii to make
sure that there was no world war three
yeah and they were like we're going to
use the british and the american
governments to establish military
dominance isn't that a good isn't it a
good thing
about world war ii according to
kissinger yes and so we're just going to
do limited wars it will avoid a hot
total war
but you can see that it's i think the
time for limited war is over
it served its purpose we did a world war
iii are you advocating now for total war
no i'm advocating for no war i don't
think we need more anymore i mean we're
we're getting
your replacement all the time violence
doesn't work anymore yeah you become the
villain instantly when you engage in
that stuff
we're getting there we're molecularly
printing you know water and food we'll
be able to do that pretty soon
so we're very close we've got to build
them replicators
and that's it but but i will say too
that's it we're almost there qed
post scarcity bro post scarcity people
are printing food
we already live in an abundant world
just looking at all of the fat people in
america
yep we live in a world of abundance
we're designed to live in a world of
scarcity this is the one thing i try to
hammer into my kids brains
constantly bro what not just fat people
fat homeless people right we have people
who are homeless
and morbidly obese that's that's like
that's i don't know if it's a testament
to capitalism or like
a a detriment you know or it's a
it's a prime example of the way our
society has evolved faster than our
physical
physical being right we we we are
creatures of worlds of scarcity
now living in a world of abundance and
we just don't know how to operate
right we don't operate ironically think
about this a man with chiseled eight
pack
like you yeah not right now but by
summer time i promise
uh get that beachbody that's a sign of
status to appear as though you're
emaciated
yeah like what is that as the world
turned up but these
these guys these guys who do the the
like the photo shoots of the super
muscles and everything they dehydrate
themselves oh yeah of course
you have to drop a lot of the water so
that the muscles come through the skin
better
yeah and it was top-down lighting is
always really healthy i was i was i
think i was reading something from jason
moma who was aquaman
and he posted a picture something
happened where like he was at the beach
and they posted a photo saying he's
really let himself go and he literally
didn't he was still doing the training
program he was just like
it's crazy that you think just like
having skin
and looking this way having like
hydrated skin you think is letting
yourself go because they're so used to
these movies
where they're like emaciated let me just
say one thing if you've ever seen brad
pitt and fight club
thor with this shirt off for a second or
the wolverine or whatever just know
that those guys they train like six
months for that
one day for that one shot where they
have their shirt off and that is not
real and that is not sustained
and that's with guys that are on
steroids with personal trainers and
personal
chefs and they can only maintain that
for just a few days for that photo shoot
and i think
it's totally unrealistic i think
hemsworth who plays thor said he was
eating like several pounds of fish and
chicken every day
because you need that much protein to
maintain the mass yeah
and then they do the sh they film the
movie over the month and then he goes to
a lighter you know training thing where
he's not
breaking himself back to a normal guy
gerard butler is training for 300 he
played leonidas
is amazing i think there's a youtube
short 10 minute video about it's really
powerful
nevertheless it is interesting how we
need to adapt to a world of abundance
when we're
uh accustomed to a world of scarcity
yeah good point so you we're brainwashed
we basically to think that there's not
enough not brainwashed
through all time and history there has
not been enough
and now you can order any vegetable any
fruit more or less
on the internet i mean that's a problem
it is it seems like it has become a
problem it is a problem it's a problem
that you can order strawberries in
winter
because they got to grow them in like
mexico and then put them on a
freight and then ship it all the way out
it's it's it's a huge waste of energy
for
a luxury it's a luxury i get it it's
great
but in that capacity i think people
should get back to like
we need to get back people should put
chickens on the like you know we got to
get chickens man
you buy a chicken brother i saw a tweet
yeah i'm all about it let's get some
chickens we got uh
so this is this is my shout out to all
the people who are upset about joe biden
and the stimulus check and i think
that's like the
what we're starting the segment off with
you can get mad the government's not
gonna give you that money
but what are you gonna do about it what
are you gonna do you're gonna sit there
and be like i'm mad
all right here's a solution you got to
be self-sustainable i don't want a
solution
and that's fine you can be mad if you
want but then you're going to be hungry
and mad
you could sell an instagram account buy
baseball gloves and resell them at
retail
yeah or shoes or or united cic signs for
all over the places people have chickens
and they sell the eggs
yeah they collect them all and then
after a certain amount of time they eat
them if they go
if they're too old but then the fresher
ones they always have available for sale
300 eggs per year per hen
get on it 300 eggs yeah per year per
head
if you do it right i learned that by
watching homestead rescue one of my
favorite shows on tumblr oh cool but so
so this is an important point though
uh you know we were talking the other
day with ryan ryan long about
whether or not this was one of the one
of the tim cast member segments whether
or not
society will irreparably change
completely when they release the
lockdown finally how different will
everything be and i was like i think
it'll be different forever
i think it's it's done it's different
new normal is here
the habits you had are gone regular
people
yeah absolutely i mean i hear what
you're saying but like
i'm thinking about this summer and
lockdowns being released
and all i can think about is getting my
ass back down to miami and going to a
pool party
and drinking and dancing to house music
and being around beautiful people
and that's exactly what i did i didn't
say that wouldn't happen i know but like
i'm saying those are my normal habits
right right so so people who used to go
to the movies and haven't gone to the
movies in over a year might go to a
movie but now hbo max is publishing
movies at the exact same time really
really
yup so when the movie comes out now it's
on streaming services already
and guess what friends have already
formed movie night groups
where they're like hey it's friday let's
do movie night now a movie comes out
they're like oh we can go see movie
night let's do movie night let's watch
the new movie they don't go to the
theater anymore
habits are being changed completely so
here's what i say
you can't count on the government man
you can cross your fingers and hope
it'll be there for you but that's not a
guarantee
well people don't seem to understand on
the left i don't care if you call it
government
i don't care if you called a nonprofit i
don't care if you called a corporation
it is an organization that's it and
really really big ones
tend to suck comcast everybody complains
about comcast
it's a monopoly in my area they don't
answer their phones great so why do you
think the government being in trouble
something is going to change that
it's the same thing what's the
difference let me ask a question
you know the only real difference in my
opinion between let's say you live in an
area
where you have comcast and then you have
you know government you know provided
service of some sort
like um you could only get your
electricity or or waste management is a
government program
what's the difference you pay a
subscription fee you get the service
you can complain here's the thing about
government i like better
you have rights if you have a problem
with government you can escalate it to
the authorities
these private corporations like facebook
or comcast
can do whatever what are you gonna do
i'm suing them because they won't give
me internet
you can try maybe there's a reason they
might give you internet or they'll just
be like sorry too bad go home
and you can vote the government people
out of power if they do a poor job
so there's that incentive so that's what
i'm saying is i think
a monopoly a private monopoly is worse
than a public monopoly but you need to
understand the difference is very very
slim
if you say the government should run
this entire system right here you're
basically saying
i want a massive amount i want comcast
taking care of my healthcare
i don't know about all that but i'm
actually in favor of a base level
coverage
with private hospitals and private
insurance so there's some there's still
some kind of like universal care
i i've often talked about this maybe
what we really need is that
the government acts as a referee or
provides vouchers
and that's it there's no government-run
healthcare there's no government-run
schools it's vouchers we all pay the
taxes
then the government says we make sure
people don't go below a certain
threshold
people who are wealthier are gonna
naturally pay more because ten percent
of a million is way more than ten
percent of a hundred
and that means poor people will get
access by voucher to these programs but
does that mean that taxpayers have to
pay for the vouchers
and yes so they're still lying in the
pockets of exorbitant prices of these
private medical industry
but now you've got you've got
competition
you simplify the system i'm not saying
it's a perfect idea i'm saying
it might be a way this it might be a
good solution right because we've talked
to um
who's who's the uh i'm forgetting the
guy's name the the uh d'angelus corey
angela
cory a private a school choice guy yeah
he's a great guy but we we've also
talked about police choice
fire department choice every kind of
hospital choice i mean it makes a lot of
sense what if you you got
vouchers for specific services and then
you had to choose who delivered those
services
you'd have market competition with a
public guarantee
or or we could just stop taxing
everybody so much let you have your
money and then go make your own
the problem with that is there are
people who like i don't like the idea
look i'm a bit left in that regard i
don't like i don't like the idea that
somebody works at mcdonald's full-time
80 hours a week maybe double time and
they can't go to the doctor
so what happens is then you have
extremely wealthy people
you want to argue flat tax or
progressive tax fine the simple
the simple answer is if some dude makes
a million bucks and pays 10 percent
he's paying more than someone who makes
a thousand bucks into paying 10 percent
he's paying more to taxes so that will
help offset the costs only a little bit
to be completely honest
and i am a fan of the progressive tax
and i think then we have a base level so
people aren't
you know going medically bankrupt
charter schools is something i know a
lot about
i spent 10 years working in charter
schools i was a executive director of a
multiple different charter schools i was
a top
regulator one of the most advanced
charter school regulators in the country
i know school choice it is a radical
right-wing
public policy experiment because it is
it's about
solving what was a public
issue with private entities right so
charter schools are privately owned
publicly funded
and the same concept could apply to
everything like you just said police
fire
medical and what we've seen with charter
schools is that they
deliver per dollar better results
right per on a per dollar basis and what
we've seen in washington dc is that
about half of the the students in dc go
to charter schools
and what happened at the beginning is
charter schools at first outperformed
but now that it's actually half and half
they're actually performing relatively
the same
right so that means that they're
delivering the same product but they do
it with far less money
yeah they do it with far less money they
have far
more they're far more nimble they can be
shut down if they're terrible schools
and they don't meet standards
it's a really good system and the irony
for me in working in that environment is
that
truly a radical right-wing policy
experiment implemented
in dc by georgia senators in the 90s
right
republicans completely staffed by
radical left-wing social justice
warriors that have no idea that they're
participating in the deconstruction of
the federal government
that they that they so love and hold and
hold dear but i i would love to see this
thing
see it expanded but what happens though
you know
same arguments as they make about
charter schools it's like what happens
when you know the rich people get all
the good cops and the poor people get
all the bad cops or you rich people get
all the good
vouchers are equal bro the vouchers are
equal
yeah so when it comes to certain
services
everybody has the same vouchers i see oh
i see you're just like i get fire
service from this company i can just
choose to go to this company or that
company but they're local
that's the problem is like if if
everybody in one area wants the good
cops and they
pay their vouchers to it then all these
people in different area also want the
good cops and pay their vouchers
so then population density will lead to
better so so then a new police
department will open up to serve that
demand oh interesting yep
it's an interesting idea uh i'd like to
see it explored
you know a little bit better i don't
know ain't gonna happen in this
administration
my friend they hate school choice more
than they hate you know
syrians and drugs they like the teachers
vote they want those votes
yep thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you